of course there is another story that
we're all incredibly happy about and
it's the return to positive scores with
a former legend gary kasparov there's no
former legend you're just a legend and
he remains legends never die there
forever and this legend indeed showed
that his style and skill and
determination and fighting spirit are
still burning
bright inside gary
not quite all the way but still you've
got to be proud of a number of things
you did in this tournament yeah yes i i
i had a good start today so that work
and peter played poorly so and i scored
again and uh and for a second you know i
thought wow so this is you know i'm
tying first you know maybe you know i
have a chance you know just to have just
the it's my
swan song
uh and uh
and with hikaru you know that was
it's sometimes you know this is you have
to take your chances you have to take
risk and with shikaru so i i repeated
moves and the position was
i had to calculate the idea with f4 and
i saw it and i wasn't sure and i said oh
why should i take this risk now so just
you know it's and the repeated moves
that was a bad decision yeah we thought
we felt like
you would you would go for it yeah but
it's 95 f4 yeah it seems it worked i
don't know i didn't have engine but i
wasn't sure and again that's that's a
problem you know this is i'm not you
know
not
at my prime so i wasn't but i had to
take my chance so that's it's it's
because you know i knew instinctively
that could be something there but i
missed couple of things and i thought
maybe i just i have to you know just uh
get some some some
reserve some strength before the last
round because i every you know every day
round three was a big challenge for me
so i i couldn't play well so just a lot
of pressure and uh um
and in the last round it's just uh it's
it's
it started poorly because he played g4
and i
and i wanted to play i'm not sure the
idea of h5 g6 is a bad one but i could
make a move c6 wait
and and then you know i just i played
immediately h5 and i think i i managed
actually to to
to create control chances and i just you
know too tired so because this i missed
few really good moments mvl pointed out
at one point i would play f6
and then i also could play a5 instead of
b5 actually when i played b5 as ah it's
the and then even there you know that's
just you know instead of stupid move e4
which is losing instantly i i could have
played bishop d7 i know i'm worse but
again it's just still a game still still
a game but it's just i again i i like
was mommy the arab so round three is
tough and uh and also i
when i started playing round three so
today so i was still thinking how could
i not take my chance against nakamura
because that was my chance to win the
tournament and i just you know blew it
up
well you did
not blow it in this game again sam this
must be one you're really proud of
you'll remember from this tournament
yeah it was quite an easy game but you
know you may call it a strategic
masterpiece
well indeed it was
your result says uh actually what mvl
said was it shows that you can still
play and maybe there's a few more
tournaments in you will we see you still
compete i will i will get i will do what
i did over this last few years so
definitely i'll play you know next uh
champion showdown in in saint louis
maybe i play zagreb just to rehabilitate
myself for this for this horrible
performance so again it just it's
somehow just i need to get my my act
together but
clearly you know 960 you know should be
much better because i don't have to
spend time repeating something i'm not
in it you know it's opening theory here
i can just come to the game and just
move the pieces and
yeah not you know sometimes you know i
don't do best best move in the opening
but eventually you know i i start fresh
again
energy
running low uh round three was always
challenge so this is every every day
round three you know i just had a
problem and today i tried to save save
some strengths for the round three but
yeah it just didn't work out so pdp
maybe maybe it's all suppression because
this is i said wow i could be in a
tiebreak i could do wow this is it was
so so um unexpected yes that was been
exciting to be to be playing for first
yeah exactly for a while
maybe you know maybe number one you know
that that somebody drawn for me you know
just
at the opening ceremony so maybe that's
still that was that was an omen but no
that's it it would be bad so just for
for for me winning as my wife says you
know gary you're an amateur you cannot
win such a touchdown because otherwise
you know this is these these guys could
get crazy
it's wrong yeah yeah but it just says
who could i imagine that in round one i
played the winner of the tournament
incredible yeah actually incredible
indeed well you regale us always we know
your passion for the game we know your
contribution to the game continues
you've been a wonderful ambassador and
this tournament you all had us cheering
for you congratulations your performance
we look forward to the next time